most cities are built on stone Braavos
was built on ships or more specifically
their cargo slaves who rose up against
their Valyrian captors and seized the
helms of the convoy of all crimes
Valyria punished rebellion most severely
the slaves faced not execution by the
Valyrian mines or labor camps in the
most remote and savage colonies if
recaptured and few corners of the world
can long remain hidden from dragon back
however our histories claim that a group
of slave women prophesied the slaves
would find shelter in a distant Lagoon
behind a wall of pine-clad hills and sea
stones where the frequent fogs would
help hide the refugees from the eyes of
dragon riders passing overhead and so it
proved because they had risked their
lives in the name of freedom the mothers
and fathers at the new city vowed that
no man woman or child in Braavos should
ever be a slave this is the first law of
Braavos engraved in stone on the arch
that spans the long canal for over a
hundred years Braavos hid itself from
the eyes of the world who called it the
secret city using a dye derived from a
local snail a captain's stained their
sails purple to hide their stolen
Valyrian ships our merchants carried
false charts and lied when questioned
about their home port eventually one see
Lord our elected ruler decided enough
time and passed and initiated the
unmasking of Braavos to the world and to
Valyria of course it helped that the
iron bank made handsome restitution to
the Dragonlords with the stolen ships
whilst of course refusing to pay for the
value of the slaves themselves the
anniversary of the unmasking is
celebrated every year in Braavos with
ten days of feasting and masked revelry
the festival like none other
culminating at midnight on the tenth day
when the Titan rose and tens of
thousands of celebrants removed their
masks as one freed of the constraints of
secrecy Bravo's quickly grew into the
wealthiest and most powerful of the Free
Cities and one could argue the most
beautiful from the sprawling sea Lords
palace with its menagerie of strange
beasts and birds so the imposing Palace
of Justice and the aqueduct we call a
sweet water river the bears fresh water
from the mainland Braavos is without
rival in either engineering or elegance
the temples of Braavos are also famed
throughout the world and wondrous to
behold descended from a hundred
different peoples the Braavosi honor a
hundred different gods the temple of the
moon singers is the foremost of these
being the faith of the slave women whose
prophecies led our ancestors here the
Lord of Light has a great temple as well
for his worshippers have grown ever more
numerous in the past hundred years yet
less numerous and even some forgotten
faiths still have temples deep in the
heart of the city on the Isle of the
Gods but the beauty of Braavos is not
only in her buildings but a vocies
swordsmanship is renowned throughout the
world
our Bravo's issue the armor and long
swords of the Westerosi Knights
preferring speed agility and slender
blades the greatest Bravo's call
themselves water dancers after the
custom of dueling upon the moon pool
near the sea Lords palace by tradition
the greatest of all the Bravo's is the
first sword who commands the personal
guard of the sea Lord and protects his
person at all public events once chosen
sea Lords serve for life inevitably
there are always those who wish to cut
that life short to affect some change in
policy though not even the first swords
are the true guardians of Braavos that
honor goes to the Titan who protects the
entrance to the harbor with his proud
head and fiery eyes looming close to 400
feet above the sea the Titan is a
fortress of a kind never seen before or
since his eye is a huge beacon fires
fighting the way for returning ships
into the lagoon within his bronze body
are holes and chambers
murder holes and arrow slits enemy ships
can be seared onto the rocks by the
watchman inside the Titan and stones and
pots of burning pitch can be dropped
onto the decks of any that attempt to
pass between the Titans legs without
leave this has seldom been necessary
however not since the century of blood
has any enemy been so rash as to attempt
to provoke the Titans rock it should an
enemy break through into the lagoon
however he would face the walls of
Braavos again not of stone like other
cities but of ships the arsenal of
Braavos can build one of our famous
purple hulls war galleys in a single day
all the vessels are constructed
following the same design says all the
many paths can be prepared in advance
and skilled shipbuilders work upon
different sections of the vessels
simultaneously to hasten the labor to
organize such a feat of engineering is
unprecedented war need only look at the
raucous confused construction in the
shipyards around the world to see the
truth of this let us imagine that even
the Arsenal great as it is failed us an
enemy who could defeat both the Titan
and our fleet would be strong indeed
but Braavos does not depend only on
statues and ships we also have iron and
gold